let's go next to Daniel from Taiwan
Daniel welcome
hey David how are you I'm doing well
I was just
um uh I mean for what would you tell
somebody that's in Taiwan that's uh
increasingly maybe concerned about being
invaded by
an authoritarian regime that shall not
be named yeah I would be
um I would be very very much
uh sensitive to what what may become a
precarious situation I mean listen I
said weeks ago I think China's paying
attention to what's happening in Russia
and Ukraine to see what is Russia
allowed to get away with and as a result
what might China be allowed to get away
with when it comes to Taiwan I am I
don't want to say I'm expecting
aggression but I am
thinking it's quite plausible that there
will be aggression towards Taiwan from
China so I don't know I mean I would I
would be paying attention to what local
government is saying
yeah I mean there's I mean there's a
couple things that I'd like to say about
this um I I did send you an email about
this um I don't know if I mean I'm sure
you get a lot of emails so it's probably
just lost in the weeds there but um
they I don't like the I I don't like the
fact that uh China gets to have their
you know state-run media and propaganda
channels on
Western social media like Facebook
Twitter Instagram uh they have you know
plenty of YouTube channels they're just
spreading their propaganda and you know
I just checked on Facebook only one of
their uh Statewide media channels just
one they have many and just one has over
a million and a hundred million
followers on Facebook
and I just and and obviously
they're not allowed to have you know any
media channels that they don't approve
of over there so I just see that as like
this unfair balanced where they get to
very successfully spread the propaganda
outside their borders but not the other
way or not receive the other way around
that's a fair criticism
yeah and and it it really it really
affects the conversation publicly and I
I just don't I just don't like that
um I I don't want to take up too much
time but I I also just like to say that
um the People's Republic of China which
is their official's name has never
governed Taiwan in any Century decade
year month week day hour minute second
in history it's never happened before
um and I would I send you an email
suggesting an expert on the topic
um they maybe have on the show
um okay all right Daniel from Taiwan
thank you you've said it all one of our
sponsors is splendidspoon now if you're
like me I love planning my meals out for
the week but sometimes I just run out of
time to plan them for every single day
and Splendid spoon makes that whole
process a lot easier they deliver fresh
delicious plant-based meals right to
your door ready to eat no cooking no
cleaning dishes saves you a a lot of
time you can choose from over 50 hot and
cold meal options there's smoothies
grain and noodle bowls soups I'm a big
soup guy many of you know that I also
really liked the vegan meatballs with
marinara noodles delicious both eye and
Splendid spoon believe eating more
plant-based is a great tool for feeling
good for helping the environment the
list goes on I'm not vegan you all know
that I think but Splendid spoon is
really great to just help me maximize
the proportion of plants in my diet
Splendid spoon takes all of the work out
of tasty healthy plant-based meals and
you'll save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com Pacman the link is
down below